oui j'aimerais savoir pourquoi tu n'as
pas signer ce fameux contrat pour le
combat en tunisie parce que c'était un
contrat déjà le contrat qui m'a qui nous
a envoyé ce n'est pas le contrat que lui
a signé mais il paraît il n'apparaissait
pas sur le contrat ceux qui l'organisent
c'est un truc de touriste rien à voir
avec ils ont jamais organisé entre de
mma tunisie c'est beaucoup trop loin
le but du jeu c'est que tout le monde
puisse y assister quand même c'est un
show même si on s'est bagarré c'est un
show et voilà danemark et booba et
l'autre artissime sont mêmes pas écrit
sur le sur le contrat d'accord alors
dames et agit sur installa dessus
regardez ça va arriver c'est en train de
caler ça va en régie merci
laisse tomber oui vous n'avez pas envie
de vous mettre tous les deux autour
d'une table et de discuter plutôt que de
vous battre peut-être peut-être qu il ya
des malentendus de parts et d'autres
peut-être de vous dire maintenant on a
passé le choc de sa vague et que la
bagarre mais il ya plein de gens booba
qui disent pro vous mettez pas dans un
ring et vous faites un clash de vannes
non y'a plein de gens qui tout ça parce
qu'il ya plein de gens sur twitter
qu'ils disent mais qu'est ce tu lui
réponds ça m'intéresse pas un clash
ouais ouais ça t'intéresse pas non
pourquoi
wayne on va faire le frapper